z. du gehst irgendwie kannst du nicht
backen oder was ne glaubst du dass
Verstorbene noch bei uns sind oh wow ja
sehr schön hast Du toll gemacht super
aus aber persönlich muss ich sagen habe
noch keinen besseren Cheesecake gegessen
hallo ihr Lieben heute gibt's wieder
eine neue Folge kiky meats mein heutiger
Gast ist bon und er ist
da erstmal würde ich dich gerne
vorstellen ich denke ihr kennt alle bon
aber du hast mal gesagt in dem Interview
ich habe ja ein bisschen geschaut du
bist einfach gerne beyon aber bist du
denn auch darf ich sagen
Motivationsredner oder hast du da
irgende anderen Begriff weil du bist ja
wirklich schon sehr speziell auf eine
positive Art und Weise ja ach du darfst
alles sagen ne also fast alles aber ich
glaube ne also viele Menschen wollen
auch immer so brauchen so Schubladen
weißt du die müssen sagen du bist das du
bist dies und so das war echt schwer für
mich irgendwie ne weil bist du jetzt
Coach Autor bist du Podcaster irgendwie
und ich fand so bon ist so ich ich
möchte einfach dass Menschen schaffe
loszulassen die ganzen Erfahrungen und
den Schmerz den ich so im Leben gemacht
habe weil der ist so tief gespeichert
dass am Ende nur noch Selbsthass bleibt
für mich wenn du dich selbst hassen
würdest ja dann würdest du jetzt nicht
hier sitzen und vor 1500 Menschen eine
Frage stellen erstmal ja so viel Mut ist
muss man erstmal entwickeln ne da muss
ein Funken Selbstliebe sein ich habe
genau so gedacht wie du wirklich und
viele Menschen denken vielleicht genau
also ihr hört schon bon macht vieles und
wenn ich eins sagen kann immer wenn ich
deine Videos auf meiner for you page
habe oder auch aktiv konsumiere bin ich
danach immer so boah Bo jetzt kann ich
den Tag starten ja jetzt geht's los bin
ich richtig motiviert W ich sagen ja ich
fre mich auch alsoast ein Händchen für
ich bin auch ein großer Fan und ich kann
ich ich war ja schon ehrlich aber gesagt
backen ist nicht so meins aber du hast
eine so tolle Ausstrahlung und ich
wollte unbedingt mit dir Backen deswegen
freue ich mich einfach und wir haben
schon mal eine Gemeinsamkeit wir lieben
beide Cheesecakes und deswegen habe ich
heute lass den Namen auf der Zunge
zergehen m wir machen einen Karamel
makiato Cheesecake Cheesecake hört sich
das gut an geil bist du ein Karamell Fan
Karamel superel Kaffee ja alles super
alles super perfekt perfekt super dann
starten wir jetzt und da du ja so gerne
backst lass ich dir mal den Vortritt
okay so als erstes machen wir den
Keksboden währenddessen habe ich so ein
paar Fragen an dich und auch ein paar
Fragen aus der Kik Community da kam ein
paar interessante Fragen rein kann ich
auch irgendwas machen einfach rein ja
ich bin ein sehr guter Arbeiter ich
kriege Anweisung und ich kann super
umsetzen sagen was ich du kannst die K
da reinun alle alle und dann werden die
schön fein gemixt das ist unsere Basis
unser Boden genau und für euch schreibe
ich das genau Rezept natürlich hier
unten in die Infobox und hier habe ich
jetzt eine Mischung aus Backkakao und
Kaffee und das kannst du auch einfach
mit reingeben okay und dann alles schön
zusammen miixen das ist Kaffee genau das
ist löslicher Kaffee und ich wollte
einfach so eine kleine Kaffeenote weil
das ist ja mein Lieb Getränk ist halt
der eiskaramell Machiato aus unserem
Kaffee und inspiriert davon dachte ich
mir Verein ich das Ganze zu einem
Cheesecake weil wir beide ja so
Cheesecake wie Power sind hmer so jetzt
darfst du einmal mixen bis alles richtig
schön fein krümelt hier drauf ne sag dir
gar nicht wie es geht oh mein Gott tut
mir leid alles gut alles g du merkst ne
wir müssen bei Null anfangen bei mir ja
okay einfach da rein ja irgendwie so das
ist
dann okay kaum ist der bonda hat mein
ganzes Equipment
geschrottet geschrottet nein okay
drückst du hier und da gleichzeitig
drauf hier oben auch
ja
inzwischen das ist wirklich
Premiere es sieht perfekt aus super
gemacht so kann ich euch nur empfehlen
ja das also wirklich was denn das Gerät
das Verkaufen nicht das
bra
da kannst du jetzt gerne schon mal die
Butter reintun ich hole uns den
Tortenring mhm und dann möchte ich gerne
mit Dir schon mal über ja deine
Jugendzeit sprechen das ist das was mich
total interessiert hat weil du hast mal
erzählt dass du Sozialstunden leisten
musstest ähm ja ja ja genau also meine
Jugend war sehr sehr gemischt ne also
m ich bin in Hagen aufgewachsen geboren
aufgewachsen und wir haben echt auch
viel missgebaut früher muss man ehrlich
sagen ja darfst du auf den Mist eingehen
im Detail ja also das war jetzt keine so
dramatischen Verbrechen oder so ne aber
wir haben oft uns geprügelt ne wir haben
oft irgendwie dann so bisschen wir
hatten so viel Energie irgendwie ne und
auch viel Langeweile und ich sage auch
ganz ehrlich ich war auch in so einem
falschen Umfeld einfach unterwegs ne
ohne jetzt Verantwortung abgeben zu
wollen aber da haben uns echt irgendwie
so diese dieser ausleich hat uns gefehlt
irgendwie und und einmal haben uns auch
geprügelt mit anderen Leuten oder
anderen Kids im Prinzip so wie alt warst
du da ungefähr damit ich mir ein
bisschen besser vorstellen kann so 16 17
ja und dann musste ich eine
Jugendherberge tapezieren in mein
Sozialstunden das war sehr lehrreich auf
jeden Fall ja weil danach kam auch
irgwann die Kurve habe ich gemerkt
irgendwann e was machst du da eigentlich
weißt du ich habe mit mein Eltern ich
meine Eltern weinen sehen und mein Vater
hab m ich nie weinen sehen wirklich das
erste Mal ja mein Vater hat da geweint
und meine Mutter hat geweint auf dem
Bett sitzen beide und habe ich den
gesagt ich ändere irgendwas ich wusste
nicht was ich machen soll wie ich das
machen soll und habe ich angefangen
wirklich dann in die Bücherei zu gehen
hab angefangen Bücher zu lesen zum Thema
Glück zum Thema Lebensfreude irgendwie
und ich WUs g da wurde das eingepflanzt
quasi was du heute machst also ist das
so dein dein Knackpunkt gewesen im Leben
ein Aha Moment ja das lag immer das lag
mir schon immer wirklich ich war immer
schon so ich wollte immer Menschen
helfen ich war sehr empathisch ich war
jetzt kein schlechter Mensch oder so ich
war immer sehr empathisch ich war
Klassensprecher hab mich für gegen
Ungerechtigkeit eingesetzt hat immer
schon in mir geschlagen so dieses dieser
Wunsch Menschen zu helfen aber irgendwie
hat man manchmal im Leben ist das so
weil manchmal im Leben gehst du
irgendwie ein falschen Weg oder links
oder rechts wichtig ist einfach dass du
glaube ich reflektierst dass du
verstehst du musst was ändern und dann
etwas anderes machen sehr schön gesagt
ja und da habe ich wirklich ganz viele
ganz viel Zeit in der Bücherei verbracht
und viele Bücher gelesen sehr schön ja
die Eltern Wein zu sehen finde ich ist
ein ganz ganz ganz schlimme Sache also
ich finde das es gibt für mich
persönlich gibt schlimmeres als die
Eltern irendwie traurig zu sehen ne aber
ja man sagt ja auch immer zeig mir deine
Freunde und ich sag dir wer du bist und
wenn man deine falschen klicke ist oder
auch irgendwie da so reingerätt dann ja
das war also oh wie gesagt man muss
schon die Verantwortung übernehmen man
selber hat ja auch irgendwie diese
Menschen angezogen warum auch immer aber
wichtig ist einfach dass du verstehst
irgendwie okay wenn etwas nicht gut
läuft ich muss was ändern ja und dann
einfach irgendwie anderen Schritt zu
gehen und ja aber alles hat mich auch
stärker gemacht weißt du also ich würde
auch glaube ich nichts ändern vielleicht
ne also wenn man jetzt zurückblickt weiß
willst du was ändern frag man ganz
häufig das eine ganz typische Frage ne
würde ich was ändern ne also ich denke
auch immer aus den Fehlern die ich immer
gemacht habe habe ich immer mein resume
gezogen was gelernt nein es sind
meistens eher so Sachen vom Timing her
dass ich gesagt hät ich damit mal früher
angefangen oder hät ich das mal eher
gemacht ne eher solche Sachen aber nee
Fehler macht man ja auch um daraus zu
lernen tatsächlich und weißt du das
kommt ja auch nicht so einfach ne also
z.B warum waren wir oftmals wütend ne
also wir als als Kids oder Jugendliche
oder junge Erwachsene das hing auch mit
vielen Faktoren zusammen wir hatten z.B
eine Truppe da waren sehr viele
Ausländer ne oder Menschen mit
Migrationshintergrund ne wir hatten
Araber Türken Afrikaner ich war dabei
und wir hatten z.B wir sind nie in
Diskotheken reingekommen ne wir hatten
teilweise mal so fünf Diskotheken an
einem Abend in die wir nicht
reingekommen sind so und dann hat das zu
Frust geführt und zu Wut geführt also
ich will jetzt gar nicht sagen so wo
aber wo ist die Wurzel wo ist die
Ursache wo ist die Wirkung das hat alles
zueinander geführt auch weißt du dass
wir irgendwann da so saßen und und so
einfach so eine tiefe Wut hatten uns ja
wir war nicht immer irgendwie Opfer von
Rassismus oder so aber auch das hat dazu
beigetragen dass man hat geprägt klar
auf jeden Fall definitiv also ich merke
das ja auch ne gerade wir mit
Migrationshintergrund wir sind hier die
Ausländer aber auch bei uns in der
Heimat wenn ich in der Türkei bin ich da
auch die deutsche die Ausländerin ne und
deswegen sage ich immer wenn ich zu
Terminen gehe mit Hamsa wir müssen erst
rechtpünktlich sein wir müssen erst
recht saaubere Kleidung tragen einfach
damit die Leute denken a nicht wieder
hier die die Ausländer die immer das
Klischee erfüllen leider wie es halt so
ist ja aber ich hab Gefühl muss immer
einmal mehr beweisen ja ja also ich kann
nachvollziehen was du gesagt hast weil
ich war auch sogar für meine Familie in
Indien war ich der deutsche ne also
sogar die haben gesagt da ist der
deutsche wieder so ne das war wirklich
so ähm aber ich glaube
äh also es gibt ein paar Tendenzen die
so ein bisschen vielleicht nachdenklich
machen aber es gibt auch viele gute
Tendenzen ich finde auch die Welt wird
insgesamt ein bisschen kleiner auch über
die Digitalisierung ähm über
verschiedene Trends finde ich schon
irgendwie äh auch über generell das
Internet finde ich ne man hat viel mehr
zu tun mit anderen Leuten anderen
Sprachen man wächst irgendwie ne
multikultureller irgendwie trotzdem auf
finde ich ne und das sollten wir
unterstützen ja absolut ich schlag hier
mal den Tortenring ein damit backen wir
gleich unseren Cheesecake und du hattest
jetzt erzählt deine also ihr kommt aus
Indien und deine Mama ist recht früh
nach Deutschland gekommen du hattest
erzählt es gibt es gab ein
Pflegenotstand und sie ist mit 17
hergekommen genau genau jetzt wie viele
Jahre später sind das schon 40 Jahre
später 40 Jahre später wissen deine es
klingt immer so doof ne aber wissen
deine Eltern was du machst also können
die das Nachvollziehen ja teilweise
schon also die verstehen z.B so Bücher
ne das können sie verstehen ne dann man
schreibt ein Buch und dann irgendwie ne
gibt's das irgendwo zu kaufen oder ne
lesen das Leute die Show an sich ich
habe die mal eingeladen zu verschiedenen
Shows die sitzen da so und die begreifen
das nicht so richtig ne also warum wieso
ne warum sind alle dann so begeistert
oder also ich kenne das z. auch von mir
wir sind ja auch ja am Anfang was macht
ihr da wie ihr steht da und macht
Rezepte aber die besuchen deine Shows
regelmäßig oder regelmäßig heißt in der
Nähe auf jeden Fall im Ruhrgebiet oder
so ne oder Köln Düsseldorf Ecke aber so
richtig begreifen die denkt manch so
warum kommen die da zu dem Jungen und
wollen reden hören und so ne und bei mir
ist so wenn irgendwie auch Leute mich
ansprechen auf der Straße und ich mit
meinen Eltern unterwegs bin dann denken
die immer das sind Freunde von mir dann
sagen die immer so kennst du den ne knst
du die kannst du den
ne ein bisschen schwer zu begreifen und
ich glaube auch manchmal ich so so so
kleine Videos oder Stories mit meiner
Mutter die weiß nicht was dahinter
passiert ne also das das 100tausende
sehen und so das ist für die auch
vielleicht auch besser weißt du dass es
nicht so so ganz greifbar ist ne das
aber ich glaube mittlerweile die wollten
lange Zeit dass ich irgendwie so ein
klassischen Weg gehen ne der KL bist du
ja auch am Anfang gegangen ne ja genau
genau oder also nach Abitur hat mein
Vater wirklich wirklich gesagt ne B
entweder Arzt oder Ingenieur das war
mein 5050 Chance W h du dich dann
entschieden in ich so okay dann ma ich
Ingenieur ne mein Vater so ah gute Idee
dann bin ich Ingenieur geworden aber
mein Vater hat auch immer gesagt z.B das
war auch so ein Glaubenssatz von ihm
Arbeit ist Arbeit leben ist leben das
ist das finde ich traurig aber so das
das sind unsere Eltern sind genau und
dadurch habe ich halt immer gedacht okay
das macht keinen Spaß aber e Arbeit ist
Arbeit leben ist Leben ne und dann habe
ich so Praktiker gemacht bei z.B
Volkswagen in Wolfsburg hat kein Spaß
gemacht aber ich dachte mir egal Arbeit
ist Arbeit leben ist Leben ne aber
irgend hast so diese Stimme in dir die
so sagt ey das kannst nicht sein ne wenn
du so hochrechnest okay du wirst 100
Jahre alt so optimistisch ne dann 33
Jahre arbeiten kannst do nicht
wegschmeißen ne kannst nicht machen ne
und dann habe ich überlegt okay was
machst du jetzt und dann habe ich ein
irgendwann anfangen mit Videos ne
vorher noch promoviert das hat Spaß
gemacht beim bei meinem
lieblingsprofessor damals ne ja und dann
habe ich Videos gemacht kannst dir
vorstellen was dann passiert ist ne bei
mein Eltern und so ne ich habe ein
Doktor in der Tasche und machst du da
gehst jetzt irgendwie Arbeiten ne ich ma
Videos du machst Videos videosr ich find
aber auch krass dass du es einfach
gemacht hast ne und wahrscheinlich haben
auch viele gesagt hey mach doch was
vernünftiges oder ne du hast du hast ein
Doktortitel mach was draus und dann
sitzt du da und machst Videos aber du
erreichst jetzt Millionen von Menschen
das ist wirklich Wahnsinn also wir
blenden euch gerne mal was ein das ist
auch schön dass du die leuteche total
mit einbindest das habe ich so auch in
so einer Form in Deutschland noch nie
gesehen dass du wirklich Leute aus dem
Publikum einbindest und dann musst du
aber auch zack reagieren ja du immer die
perfekte Antwort parat oder gab's auch
mal Momente wo du sagst oh weiß ich
gerade nicht also
ich versuche wirklich mit dem Herzen
dabei zu sein ne so wie du ne also wenn
du mit mit deinem Kopf was backst ne
dann schmeckt das nicht so wie wenn es
von Herzen kommt weißt was ich meine ich
merke du hast immer die perfekte Antwort
auf alles was man sagt das ist
unglaublich aber es ist tatsächlich so
ja man es ist wirklich so also mit dem
Kopf sieht vielleicht perfekt aus ne
dann ist da so da der Dings die Kirsche
und so bisschen Sahne aber von Herzen
denkst du so irgendwie ne da ist
irgendas anderes und bei den Fragen ist
genauso im Endeffekt ich ich kenne die
Fragen vorher nicht ne ja und ist n
gesriptet n gesriptet nein nein auf
keinen Fall ich will auch gar nicht
wissen und ich öffne mein Herz
und ich ich ich möchte einfach diesen
Menschen helfen ne das ist so wie wenn
du jetzt z.B du gehst irgendwie kannst
du nicht backen oder was ne guck was ist
da los einmal mit
Profis deine deine Energie war zu viel
für mein
teiger das zeigt sie war so richtig
wütend
einfach komm endlich komm zum Punkt komm
zum Punkt oh Gott geil ist mir auch noch
nie passiert Premiere für
mich oh Gott ja du hast eine krasse
Energie hier in meiner kücheich
unglaublich nein und und das ist
wirklich so wenn du jetzt spazieren
gehst irgendwie ne mit einer Freundin
und dann sagt die z.B oh Kiki weißt du
was ich habe so Liebeskummer was würdst
du machen dann würdest du auch dein Herz
öff
und Versen das Beste zu geben einfach
und so ma ich auch also ohne jetzt zu
überlegen wie klingt das einfach ich
will dem helfen den Menschen also ich
finde das das kann man also das können
bestimmte Menschen ich versuche manchmal
wenn ich in so einer trösterrolle bin ne
dann weiß was was würde ich denn jetzt
gerne hören ne das kommt bei manchen gut
an und bei anderen weniger gut ne also
hast du auch schon mal erlebt das dein
Gegenüber also wenn jemand eine Frage
gestellt hat aus dem Publikum irgendwie
die ganze Zeit nachgeboht hat oder damit
gar nichts anfangen konnte hast du
solche Fälle auch mal oder findest du
wirklich immer den passenden rschlag
m also ich habe bisher waren alle
Menschen happy muss ich ehrlich sagen
m ich glaube auch viele Menschen wollen
gar nicht eine Antwort eine konkrete
Antwort sie wollen einfach mal sagen was
sie fühlen gehört werden weißt du ich
glaub ganz viele Menschen tragen sehr
viel mit sich und allein das Aussprechen
vor fremden Menschen ne tut schon so gut
und dann sitzen da so Leute und du
merkst plötzlich der kennt mich nicht
aber der lächelt mich an und sie kennt
mich nicht aber du merkst sie wünscht
mir auch dass es mir gut geht und das du
fühlst dich wohl ne schön und im
Endeffekt ich muss nur ich muss ja nicht
meine Antwort geben sondern ich muss nur
Fragen stellen so was möchtest du oder
war warum ist dir das wichtig oder warum
möchtest du es nicht oder was könnte dir
helfen und dann sagen die plötzlich
selber so ja vielleicht sollte ich das
mal ansprechen oder vielleicht sollte
ich mal nein sagen ne oder vielleicht
muss ich es mal probieren und dann sage
ich ja dann mach's doch schön und das
ist eigentlich eigentlich weiß man ja
schon und das das schöne auch im Leben
du weißt ja was dich glücklich macht wir
kommen ja alle daher weißt du also Babys
da waren wir alle offen tolerant ne da
haben wir nicht irgendwie nachgedacht
wir haben keine Hautfarben gesehen das
heißt alles steckt in uns ja es gibt
immer so Schlüsselmomente die das die
uns dazu führen dass wir dann eben
irgendwie unzufrieden sind mit irgendwas
ne ja und ich glaube auch
das ist viele Menschen denken wir
bräuchten mehr weißt du so wir brauch
ich brauche mehr Mut mehr Glück mehr das
aber wir brauchen eigentlich weniger
weißt du weniger Angst weniger Zweifel
und dann am Ende bleibt dann sozusagen
der Kern übrig weißt du wie so ein
Schokokuchen wo du alles wegnimmst
dieser
schokok du metaphorisch bist du auf soem
Level daslaublich hast du sehr schön
gesagt das
stimmt mE ist kaputt gegangen weiß was
ich jetzt machen soll ist wirklich geil
aber ne jetzt hat das das kann mehrere
Gründe gehabt haben ne du sagst Energie
es könnte aber auch Wut gewesen sein
meinst du hast du ein Hang dazu Menschen
zu zu analysieren de deines Berufs jetzt
dass du sagst die reagiert jetzt so
und nein das kannst du kannst du
abschalten klar klarlich ich glaub wenn
du wütend wärst wir man das auch ansehen
ne oder ja ich glaube auch Sel kannst du
gut wütend werden oder bist du auch
wütend doch ich schon doch Moment Dich
frage ich nicht geh
wütend guck ich jetzt die aufgab mit
diesem Pinchen hier einfach so ein
bisschen eine eine Ebene so ne genau
gerne auch so ein bisschen an den Rand
damit auch so ein bisschen hübsch
aussieht ja das Auge ist ja mit ne auf
jeden Fall W wenn du auf eine Show mal
aufst so nebenbei während der Show ich
weiß nicht das musst Du nachher sagen du
musst mal probieren ob das sich wirklich
lohnt ich ich ich mag das wirklich ich
liebe Backkunst ne ich bin nur selber
nicht so gut da drin ne ich habe mal
Waffel gebacken für meine Eltern früher
als Kind immer und hat geklappt hat
geklappt ja siehst du die haben mich
immer dann gefragt so wir voll süß ich
konnte nur nur Waffel Backen ja und die
hab mich immer gefragt bon kannst du
Waffel machen wieder ich kon nur Waffel
süß um dich so ein bisschen zu supporten
auch wahrscheinlich wir hatten eine
deutsche ich habe eine deutsche Mama
noch das ist ganz witzig weil meine
meine Eltern mussten wi der früh
arbeiten gehen ne ein paar Wochen nach
der Geburt schon und unsere ältere
deutsche Nachbarin ja du musst sagen W
ich aufhören soll ich fin das gerade so
D das sieht so gut aus D ich weit okay
okay okay eine eine deutsche Nachbarin
hat uns mit groß gezogen mein Bruder und
mich und wir wussten das damals nicht
besser D habe ich angefangen sie Mama zu
nennen also ich hte Mami ist meine meine
Mutter und Mama war sie einfach und sie
hat immer gebacken für uns und sie hat
immer Waffeln gemacht für uns meine
Mutter konnte nie Backen anders als
deine Mama ne meine Mutter konnte nie
backen oder sie wollte nicht ich weiß
nicht genau m mal rausfinden m manchmal
ist man auch zu gestresst zum Backen
weil backen ist immer dies Gramm genau
abwiegen alles immer Minuten genau
backen und so weiter ne die entspannt
meine Mutter ist entspannt ja ja auch
indische Küche ist ja auch sehr sehr
sehr sehr aufig die indische Küche ja
ich war auch mal in Indien ich wde auch
jederzeit wieder in Rajastan und in Deli
ich liebe Indien ich konnte hams noch
nicht dazu überreden noch mal mit uns zu
fliegen das sieht perfekt aus das würde
ich genauso lassen Danke schön sehr
gut ja so hamser Indien was los warum
nicht we ich auch nicht Touch Mahal ich
kann auch ein paar paar Sätze auf
indisch abkesse ho Hindi sprichst du ne
Hindi kann ich gar nicht leider ja ich
kann nur Malal sprechen ja GZ ja es gibt
ja 60 Sprachen in Indien ah ja stimmt
das war also wirklich andere Schrift ne
und also komplett anders und ich bin
froh dass ich eine wenigstens
einigermaßen kann ne so ich würde jetzt
den die Cheesecake Masse mit dir
zusammen vorbereiten willst du nicht
noch irgendwie ein paar lobende Worte
loswerden oder hast du ist das Standard
für dich nein ich finde es super dafür
dass du es noch nie gemacht hast ist ist
top top oder ja sehr sehr gut gemacht
danke schön so und jetzt kommt aber die
wir brauchen hier Aufnahme ich w ger
sagen mal rein
Lab okay wir machen die cheesecakeemasse
dafür haben wir doppelrahfrischkäse bist
du so kalori hab ich schon vorbereitet
gestern damit du nicht so viel Arbeit
hast habe ich weil normalerweise 8
Stunden dauert das ne und dann woll woll
nicht zumuten ne all vorbereit du kannst
aber raten was drin ist dann sag ich ob
es richtig ist ich soll raten was drin
hier hab ich schon verraten das ist ja
doppelr fr genau richtig ger hier was
könnte das sein vielleicht Sahne oder
schm oder SAS genau
ja Karamellsoße und Zucker und Eier du
kennst dich gut aus alles richtig ja im
nächsten Leben werde ich
Bäckerin so jetzt kannst du eigentlich
alle Zutaten rein tun der Rei nach und
dann praktisch du bist nicht so der
Bäcker aber du kochst bestimmt gerne
oder auch nicht ich bestell sehr gerne
essen und ich gerne essen okayest die
lokale ich supporte die lokale und ich
liebe es wirklich im im Restaurant zu
sitzen und wirklich ja das ist wirklich
bei mir so
also auch sehr querbeet also ich liebe
asiatisch im Moment asiatisch also also
asiatisch ist ja sehr viel ne nicht nur
indisch Sushi ist sehr sehr mein ein
Ding von mir Salat ne gerade ma ich so
ein bisschen Ernährungsumstellung auch
ne ich guck so ein bisschen wie reagiert
der Körper so auch energetisch so für
mich ist wichtig dass es schmeckt aber
dass man sich essen soll ja eigentlich
Energie spenden weiß du und viel Orts
bist du so und istst was und dann sind
die Menschen müde das ist eigentlich das
Gegenteil von dem was man machen sollte
hast mir gerade erzählt dass du
allergisch bist gegen haselnuserne alle
aus der Kik Community schreibt mal in
die Kommentare was beond da verpasst mit
un Hasel we selber ich weiß selber auch
deine Creme hät ich so gern probiert
jetzt aber wir haben ganz viele andere
Cremes ja gut so jetzt schon reinfagen
kannst du ruhig schon re kom ja alles
komplett okay also heute musst du wenn
du irgendwie Ernährungs Umstellungen
hast so ein paar Drops hier paar Ding
ne Eier Eier du kannst erstmal anfangen
zu oder du machst eigentlich wie du
magst
okay ich B gut ich bin gut ne ich bin
ganz ehrlich das machst du super war
warte warte perfekt ich bin ich kann gut
wie gesagt ich kann echt gut Aufträge
ausführen ne ich mer das was hast du
denn so für Jobs schon gemacht in deinem
Leben bevor du ja mit dem jetzigen Job
angefangen hast nebenob das ist ja ja
also nebenjobmäßig habe ich all schon
gemacht ne ich habe Zeitung ausgetragen
mit 13 Jahren schon ich habe Teller
gewaschen im Krankenhaus in der Küche
ich habe Schuhe
verkauftockerocker ich habe gekellnert
an der Bar gearbeitet welcher Job hat
denn am besten gefallen also ich mochte
jeder Job hatte was besonderes weißt du
und ich glaube auch es ist wichtig dass
du sozusagen den Sinn hinter den
Tätigkeiten so entdeckst ne weil du
könntest ja quasi sagen ja ich verteile
Zeitung ne dann ist langweilig aber du
knst auch sagen ich bin Teil der
Menschen bei deren Frühstück weißt du
dann hast du so eine denkst du so boah
geil wichtige Aufgabe ne oder Teller
waschen im Krankenhaus kannst ja sagen
irgendwie so ja toll dreckiger Teller
wird sauber oder du verstehst halt diese
saubere Teller der kommt danach auf die
Station und da ist jemand der wird
frisch operiert und dem geht's dann
vielleicht besser weißt du hast du
sofort ein Sinn dahinter weiß me
positive Sicht auf alle Dinge also du
bist das komplette Gegenteil von
Pessimismus irgendwie das ist ich fin
das schön also ist du gibst so ein ganz
anderen Blick auf die Dinger mus ich
wirklich sagen ja das ist echt krass
danke schön also eigentlich bist du
schon fertig mit rühren aber du machst
so toll du kannst ein weiter das ist
auch ein bisschen Training für mich das
ist gut
Training da kannst gerne Karamellsoße
reintun fühl zwei esslöel ist der Deckel
schon ab
das ob abmchen ach so ich dachte muss
hochziehen ach so okay du machst das wie
ich halber so oder ja perfekt ja ich
stell mir dann vor dass ein Löffel ist
ich zähle ein bis ein zwei ja und da
kommen jetzt auch noch die Eier rein und
genau und dann kannst du alles
verrühren so so langsam werde ich warm
hier ne was denn los hier weiter geht's
ne genau jetzt einfach mal alles
umrühren jetzt bist du gerade warm jetzt
ist das Rezept aber schon fast fertig ja
also ist ein relativ schnelles Rezept
ein Blitz Cheesecake ein Blitz
Cheesecake ja ja also da musst jetzt so
lange rühren bis alles zu so homogenen
Masse wird super das auch sehr
beruhigend bisschen also ich finde es
echt schön es hat was von Meditation
finde ich ist tatsächlich so wirklich
also allein dieses das dieser Prozess
macht wirklich Spaß ja und vor allem
wenn dann das Ergebnis kommt aus dem
Ofen und hast du dann noch die Deko dann
probierst du ich habe früher aber ich so
viel gearbeitet ich weiß nicht es ist
bei uns Südländern aber auch so dass du
D mit 12 schon anfängst auszuhelfen und
zu arbeiten bei uns im Kaff vor allem
und später dann mit 18 an der Tankstelle
gejobt neben dem Studium und immer wenn
ich nach Hause kam ich habe ein 12
Stunden Tag hinter mir gehabt das erste
was ich gemacht habe ist mich in die
Küche zu stellen und zu backen echt ja
weil das wirklich für mich hab ich auch
immer gemacht das glaub
ich he ich kam nach Hause ne von
foodlocker erstmal erstmal ein Kuchen
backen ne was denn los hier nein es ist
schön weißt du warum das Meditation weil
das macht so gegenwärtig ne so in dem
Moment ich guck dieses Ding an und denke
mir so okay das muss ich alles
vermischen und alle meine Sorgen sind
gerade Weg ist das tatsächlich so ja ja
also du Sorgen kommen ja oftmals wenn du
mit in Gedanken in der Zukunft bist ne
so wenn du oder Angst ne also in der
Gegenwart hat das eigentlich keine
Chance ne weil jetzt ist ja alles okay
ne das heißt meistens Angst heißt so was
kommt morgen schaffe ich das klappt das
übermorgen und deswegen ist es so
wichtig auch in der heutigen Zeit
gegenwärtig zu sein ne also einfach im
Moment zu sein und das hilft voll dabei
ich hast du denn so ein Tipp gegen das
überdenken wenn du wirklich jedes
Szenario du liegst im Bett und gehst
jedes Szenario durch was dann eben auch
in der Zukunft li kann man das
trainieren dass man das nicht mehr macht
ja also gibt mehrere Arten auf der einen
Seite du kannst dir den schlimmsten Fall
vorstellen und dann glauben dass es
wirklich passiert ne das heißt du du
wirst quasi schließ Freundschaft mit mit
dem Worst Case und aber was mir extrem
hilft ist z.B ich gehe irgendwie in die
Zukunft und sag wenn das und das
passiert ist das dann noch schlimm in
einem Jahr ist das schlimm in 5 Jahren
und oftmal sage ich nein ist nicht ne
und das Ding ist das Leben ist ja halt
nun mal so dass es es werden gute Dinge
passieren und weniger gute Dinge
passieren aber beides ist wichtig ja und
beides ist gleichzeitig da weißt du also
Menschen sagen z.B ich will nur Glück
haben und so aber das stimmt nicht weil
wenn du nur Glück hast dann weißt Du gar
nicht was Glück ist richtig du brauchst
das Gegenteil du brauchst das Gegenteil
um zu schätzen klar genau und das das
das klappt sonst nicht und deswegen sage
ich auch wichtig ist eigentlich eher so
die Bewertung von Dingen also nicht das
Sachen passieren sondern was Du daraus
mitnimmst ne jetzt sagst z.B so keine
Ahnung es regnet jetzt hier draußen dann
kannst du sagen scheiß Regen ja aber das
regnet trotzdem auch wenn du sagst
scheiß Regen ne ja man kann es nicht
ändern genau und darum ist es so wichtig
einfach Dinge nicht negativ zu bewerten
einfach auch in die Vergangenheit ne ich
könnte sagen das war schlimm das war
schlecht oder ich sag einfach was habe
ich darus gelernt was habe ich
mitgenommen ne auch aus den Zeiten die
wir angesprochen hab aus den schlechten
Zeiten ne ich habe gelernt was ich nicht
machen sollte wofür ich nicht mehr stehe
ich habe gelernt wer auf wen ich zählen
kann auf wen ich nicht zählen kann ne
das heißt heiß also das war eine sehr
sehr sehr wichtige Zeit für mich ne hast
du vollkommen Recht auch die Menschen
die du dann damals dann aus deinem Leben
quasi aussortiert hast das sind ja posit
also was heißt positive Ereignisse aber
du du holst ja deine Learnings dusus und
machst den Feder vielleicht nicht ein
zweites mal ne aber was du gesagt hast
mit wenn ich mich mit jemandem streite
oder so und ich denke ist das in in 5
Jahren oder in 5 Monaten noch schlimm
nee dann hast du es vergessen und das
hat mir auch ganz oft geholfen been
Situation einfach das ja unter Teppich
zu kehren und zu sagen
Leben geht weiter alles gut ja ja
natürlich natürlich so ich würde sagen
wenn du noch weiter rühren möchtest tut
dir kein Zwang ich bin so gegenwärtig
gerade aber schon sieht schon sehr gut
aus ne ja das kannst du jetzt auf jeden
Fall hier einmal reintun ich hle erstmal
das
Backblech ich glaub dein neues Hobby ist
das Backen gut ne ja du bist so richtig
aber diesmal weniger Aggression bitte
benutzen woll also du und ich gebe dir
das ich trau mich hier gar nichts mehr
heute okay so das kannst jetzt hier
reinkippen oder ich kipp und du kannst
die Reste rausschaben damit wir nicht
verschwenden okay ja so und jetzt einmal
rausschaben rausschaben okay rausschaben
auch so
ein ein lustiges Wort oder sich irwi
nicht so elegant an ne Schab das da mal
raus ich frage ich ich frage meine Gäste
manchmal ne wenn du ein Küchen Element
wärst oder Küchenutensil was wärst du
dann ich glaube ich wäre so ein so ein
Mixer glaube ich Mixer ja so ein
bisschen querlig bisschen so alles ein
bisschen vermischen irgendwie ja ja so
dire wieder nehmen kannst du glatt gerne
glatt verstreichen ja Mixer doch doch
doch ich finde das passt zu dir passt
und du was wärst du deswegen kam ich
darauf das wurde ich nämlich tatsächlich
gefragt ich wre ein Teigschaber weil ich
immer noch so die letzten Reste raus das
hier z.B hör mal das würde ich dir hier
Blitze blanke obwohl nee du bist echt so
ein Teigschaber ja
oder das höreidigung
an ich kam rein mir so irgendwi sieht
aus wie so ein Teigschaber weil ich habe
m nicht getraut anzusprechen jetzt wo du
selber gesagt hast ne kann ich ja auch
sagen das hat mich schon so bisschen
sehr stark an so ein
teigsch das ganze
hier ja perfekt ich würde sagen das
kommt jetzt in den
Ofen für eine gute Stunde aber du hast
ja schon vorbereitet alles vorbereitet
daher können wir gleich direkt ans
dekorier gehen aber wie gesagt das wird
jetzt erstmal gebacken ja so einmal
rüber
so der Cheesecake ist gebacken und wir
dürfen dekorieren bzw du darfst ich bin
sehr sehr stolz auf Dich ich bin stolz
auf dich ich finde das solltest Du
beruflich machen ja findest du ich finde
schon ja ja ich find das viel Talent und
ich kann dir nur empfehlen das wirklich
intensiver zu machen ich glaube ich
schlag so die Richtung ein ich mach das
mal ja mal aus wenn der noch schmeckt
dann ja dann dann mache ich gar nichts
anderes mehr als Karamel maiato
Cheesecake genau ja aber der Brauch so
ein Namen vielleicht kann auch deine
Community namensv ir dann schreibt gerne
mal rein ja finde ich auf jeden Fall
aber ich finde du solltest jetzt deine
dekorationskünste auch mal auspacken
nicht nur die
motivationünste hier so ein paar
Streifen quergitar oder sowas so in der
Art das soll ja auch gut aussehen
ja ja okay das ist bisschen ist Kunst ne
immer gleiches langweiligchen wie die
Menschen mal wie die Menschen ja das
sieht schon ganz gut aus komm jetzt
einmal einmal in die Kommentare ein paar
liebevolle Worte so wie Bond das uns
immer wieder gibt schreibt mal rein wie
macht er sich ich finde der Cheesecake
sieht richtig lecker aus ja perfekt ich
fin der sieht richtig gut aus jetzt
fehlen noch Sahnetupfer das ist hier die
Königsdisziplin wenn du das gemacht hast
dann kannst du hier echt mit Bravur
wieder rausgehen also am best a Stück
acht acht Dinge
und am besten ist wenn du das richtig
senkricht hältst und dann leichten Druck
ausübst und dann wieder abziehst okay so
ja und abziehen ja perfekt
gegenüber ja ja ich glaub wenn deine
Mama diese Szene gerade sieht wird vor
Stolz echt Wein ich glaube das wird
richtig so vier haben wir schon mal ne
zack zack ne sind sind die gut so oder
kleiner gut ne wenn dann musst du jetzt
auch die gleiche Größe haben ja ja
stimmt ja sehr schön hast Du toll
gemacht si super aus ja bist du stolz
ich bin ach ich bin immer stolz ja ich
bin sehr sehr stolz dass wir das so gut
hinbekommen haben ja ja ich fin sieht
echt und vor allem muss ich sagen also
das ist ja eine Sache aber ich fühle
mich sehr sehr wohl hier und ja möchte
bedanken dafür für die Einladung nicht
dafür ich bin froh dass du gekommen bist
und das coole ist wir haben gerade schon
drüber gesprochen im Off ich werde dich
auf deiner Tour besuchen und du hast ja
ganz viele Termine ich werde das mal bei
mir in die Infobox rein schreiben wo
bist du alles nenn mal ein paar Städte
nur damit wir mal das Ausmaße also
wirklich im Norden sind wir in Hamburg
Bremen wir sind im Süden überall München
wir sind in der Schweiz in
Österreich wir sind im Ruhrgebiet
Frankfurt also ich glaube ich wiR haben
100 Städte oder so also wirklich bis
Ende nächsten Jahres sind wir fast
überall und ich freue mich drauf mega
geil ich glaube auch sogar in bchum
überall sind wir ja wirklich also ganz
zweimal in Wien in Zürich also sehr cool
finde ich ist auch eine schöne
Geschenkidee nicht nur für sich selbst
sondern auch vielleicht für die Freundin
für den Freund für den Partner also ich
werde das auf jeden Fall unten verlinken
und dann kann man da wahrscheinlich auch
direkt die Tickets buchen und sich das
fett im Kalender markieren D kommt need
Fall ja da sehen wirs auf jeden Fall ne
ja ich werde auf jeden Fall da sein
hundtprozentig haben auch schon ja klar
so ich würde sagen wir machen jetzt noch
den Taste Test wir wollen ja auch gucken
ob es schmeckt und vielleicht können wir
dann noch rüber in den rohrpark und dort
kann ja auch ein bisschen verteilt
werden dass alle anderen auch ein
bisschen was davon haben ja gerne gerne
Hammer ja du darfst auch probieren ah
guck mal sieht super aus ne sieh super
aus ja doch und den probieren wir jetzt
ja so bon jetzt kommt der berühmte Taste
Test du übernimmst heute hamsas Position
ja gerne Herz sehr sehr gerne hams ne
also wenn ihr öfter mal irgendwie ne ein
Taster braucht dann rufen wir dich an
nichtgeben Job und vor allem musst du
super kritisch sein so haben sie nämlich
auch immer das ist richtig kritisch beim
Probieren m boah Hammer wirklich
wirklich geil freut mich das aus deineem
Munde zu hören wir also ich bin nicht
der absolute Experte ne habe ich schon
vorbereitet gestern
was ist da los einmal mit profisen aber
persönlich muss ich sagen hab noch
keinen besseren Cheesecake gegessen
ehrlich das freut mich ich fin den auch
total lecker der wird meinem
Lieblingsgetränk dem eiskaramel maiato
echt gerecht muss ich
sagen können wir uns reinlegen
un Fragen gibt jetzt noch geil du kannst
weiter genießen und ich stelle dir die
Top D Community Fragen und Du darfst
gerne weiteressen mit voll Mund zu
beantworten ist auch ein bisschen
schwierig aber doch do do doch so Genie
from the Handy fragt cooler Name übgens
glaubst du an Karma also ich glaube dass
das D wenn du Gutes tust gutes
zurückkommt das glaube ich schon genannt
werden muss weiß ich nicht ich glaub
viele Menschen die reden von Karma aber
die nutzen es negativ we die sagen so ja
du wirst schon sehen ne oder ka wird
dich kriegen und das ist halt unnötig
weißt du also ich finde einfach wenn du
das kriegst was du gibst dann sollten
wir uns nicht konzentrieren darauf was
wir kriegen wie die meisten Menschen die
denken sich so ich will das haben ich
will mehr hiervon ich will mehr
konzentriere dich auf das was du gibst
ja geh raus gib Respekt gib Liebe sei
nett zu den Menschen sei höflich und
dann kommt alles Gute zurück sehr schön
ja schön gesagt bin ich ganz ganz bei
dir es ist alles alles eine Sache des
mindsets eigentlich im Endeffekt ne dass
du wirklich sagst okay wenn ich positiv
bin sind die Leute also nehm ich auch
nur die positiven Reaktionen wahr genau
und und wie G den ersten Schritt Sel
selbst zu machen im Prinzip ne also
wieder nicht darauf zu konzentrieren und
viele Menschen wirklich halten daran
fest und sagen ich will irgendwie ich
brauche mehr vom Leben oder so rausgehen
und das Vorbild sein oder der Mensch
sein den du in deinem Leben haben
möchtest ja die Dinge tun die Du haben
möchtest und dann kommt das Gute zurück
sehr schön gesagt aber ich war immer so
nett zu den Menschen und jetzt kommt das
zurück endlich ja
jetzt deswegen siehst du sehr schön nett
sein komm der Käsekuchen zurück so die
zweite Frage die ist ein bisschen dieper
tatsächlich glaubst du dass Verstorbene
noch bei uns sind oh wow
also ich glaube schon dass dass sie in
einer dass sie in einer gewissen Form
weiter existieren ja weil wir sind ja
Energie ne und Energie kann ja nicht
verschwinden Energie kann ja nur die
Form wechseln ne also irgendwie wird es
noch weitergehen wie das wissen wir alle
nicht ne das wäre auch langweilig glaube
ich wenn wir wüssten was alles passieren
würde aber ich bin auch ein Mensch z.B
ich rede auch mit meiner verstorbenen
Oma meinem verstorbenen Opa mit Menschen
die mich schon viel zu früh verlassen
haben also ich habe schon das Gefühl
dass sie irgendwie immer da sind m auch
jetzt z.B ja also ich glaube schon
irgendwo dass vielleicht meine Oma da
irgendwo wir können sagen vielleicht im
Himmel sitzt oder irgendwo uns auch
erlebt und schon sich ein bisschen freut
dass wir diesen käekuchen essen also ich
glaube schon dass sie in einer gewissen
Form weiter existieren und auch ein
bisschen über uns Wachen in der Zeit ja
vielen Dank für den Einblick es ist auch
ich finde auch das generell Thema
glauben was das ja so ein bisschen hier
noch auch impliziert auch ein sehr
intimes Thema ist finde ich persönlich
so und dann kommt die nächste Frage
finde ich auch sehr interessant ist
Erfolg die beste Rache falls ja wie
sollte man damit umgehen also ich finde
Rache ist eine sehr schlechte
Eigenschaft ich finde der Fokus ist
wichtig weißt du wenn da jemand ist bei
dem du dich an dem Du Dich Rechen
möchtest dann hast du diesen Hass in dir
und dann bist du auf der gleichen Ebene
verstehst du also warum sollte ich ähm
die Wut eines anderen Menschen zu meiner
Wut machen ich leide ja selbst verstehst
du und deswegen finde ich Rache generell
ist keine kein schönes Motiv ne wenn Du
Erfolg haben möchtest oder Erfolg kann
ja auch seine gute Mutter zu sein ne was
Gutes zu tun Schulen aufzubauen guter
Freund zu sein was auch immer ein Buch
zu schreiben egal was es ist dann macht
das aus dem guten Motiv heraus damit du
diese Liebe und diese Freude in dir
fühlst ja und nicht gegen jemanden
arbeitest weißt du ich glaube es ist
wichtig dass du dein Fokus deine Energie
auf das lenkst was du möchtest und nicht
auf das was du nicht möchtest ne also
Mutter Theresa hat mal gesagt ich würde
niemals auf eine antikriegsdemo gehen
aber aber jeder Zeit auf eine pro
Friedensdemo viele Menschen denken das
das gleiche aber antikrieg ist eine
antierhaltung ne du bist bist du gegen
etwas das hat viel mit Wut zu tun und
pro Frieden ist was ganz anderes ne
deswegen glaube ich nutzt die Energie
nutzt die Liebe für das was du möchtest
du gibst immer so einen ganz anderen
Blick auf die Dinge und das finde ich
hat man heute im Video echt oft gemerkt
an vielen Stellen und das ist das was
ich meinte du plopppst auf in meinem
Feed ich bin direkt Motivation so
motiviert geladen und habe Bock einfach
auf den Tag und das finde ich kam
richtig gut durch heute so wenn Ihr
gerne mal eine Show besuchen möchtet
macht das wenn ihr da auch keine Zeit
hab dann schaut zumindest beim Feed
vorbei bei beyon ich werde euch alle
social Kanäle unten verlinken du bist
bei tiktok bei insta bei Facebook bei
Youtube überall also ist mir eine
Herzensangelegenheit dass da echt mal
die Kanäle abcheckt und ja ansonsten
vielen Dank dass du vorbeigekommen bist
wir machen noch ein Abstecher zum
ruhpaar verabschieden uns aber schon mal
wenn du magst kannst du gerne noch dich
selbst verabschieden von der
kunity mach gut vielen vielen dankch für
die Einladung es hat super geschmeckt
und es war eine ganz tolle Atmosphäre
ganz tolle Energie mit dir und ich freue
mich wen uns live sehen auf tourbald und
passt gut auf euch auf alles Liebe wir
brauchen geilen Namen dafür ja und lasst
Euch schmecken unbedingt also bis zum
nächsten Mal ihr Lieben tschüss
[Musik]
tschüss schockosell